four Yemenis young and old a ceasefire
can't come soon enough as many as 18
million people more than half the
country are close to starvation four
years of conflict have brought Yemen to
its knees we have no shelter we have
nothing we don't even have water our
children are sick doctors just can't
keep up with the number of malnourished
patients we receive 25 malnutrition
cases every single week our capacity
here is very limited renewed fighting
flared up in the port city of heard a
day late Monday but the UN is pushing
ahead with its efforts to broker peace
talks between the warring parties the
Yemeni government has said it would send
a delegation to talks and that came
after Houthi rebels said they'd stop
missile attacks on Saudi Arabia the
Yemeni government's major backer but as
ever in this conflict skepticism remains
this is just a way for the saudi-led
coalition to establish an excuse for
themselves and abandon their obligations
the Coalition will not stop the
aggression the aggressors do not usually
stop and they see these sorts of
ceasefire agreements as a sign of
weakness the UN hopes these suspicions
are proved wrong and that fighting
around the key battleground of her data
is soon stopped for good
beyond that Yemen needs a long-term plan
for peace and even with all sides at the
table that will be a major challenge
we're joined now by Tamara Karolos from
the charity Save the Children in sana in
Yemen Tamara thank you so much for
joining us here on TWU as we said there
is fresh fighting in ho data this is a
very important port city what does this
mean for the millions of Yemenis who are
reliant on food aid well it is a very
dangerous situation of course this is
the third escalation
since July the city now is almost
encircled there's only one named out and
obviously the port supplies 80% of the
supplies for Yemen including obviously
much-needed food aid and fuel but also
commercial food and fuel as well um but
it's not just about that I mean I guess
the situation right now in the city is
also quite dire there had been a lull
for the last few days but fighting
resumed last last item this morning
we've heard from our staff there's no
air strikes we've seen hospitals
destroyed we've seen a large number of
civilian casualties both dead and
injured especially with children in the
last 10 15 days we have to support about
15 children that have been injured
because of shrapnel or bullets and even
yesterday we heard that some of the
suppliers of food in the city had pulled
out a stocks for fear of fighting which
which creates a new situation for about
three hundred thousand people still
trapped in the city tell me we are
hearing that more Aid is coming it's
been reported that Saudi Arabia and the
United Arab Emirates will contribute
around 500 million dollars in a new aid
program for Yemen but will that make a
difference if the fighting can't be
stopped no I think this is the the
critical issue on the figures we're
working on right now in terms of eight
and a half million people who are
extremely food insecure meaning they
don't know where their next meal is
coming from
they are reliant on Aid but again
figures coming out closer to the end of
this month I will show that the numbers
increase by millions I think at one
point it's not just about the money but
obviously about stopping the conflict
but it's also about our capacity to
respond and I think if we reach a
tipping point where many more million
Yemenis are food insecure or perhaps
even pushed to be on the brink of famine
and it'll be very difficult for us to be
able to respond and to just roll that
back Tamara on the diplomatic front just
briefly if you can the UN Security
Council is going to discuss a draft
resolution later today how hopeful are
you that we're gonna see an end to the
fighting well it's rather than being
hopeful it's more of hoping I guess the
issue again that there is no viable
solution to
to this conflict except through peaceful
negotiations the alternative is
catastrophic this is the world's worst
humanitarian crisis and if the fighting
continues not just around her data but
elsewhere in the country we could see
that situation get even worse Tamir
Karolos from Save the Children in Sanaa
thank you so much for joining us